[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
that was more energetic than i normally
do ryan it was
do you prefer the energetic version i
don't mind it it's nice
you're listening to inside of you
yeah i don't want to be announcer guy
you know i never had a good voice for
years i mean all of a sudden people say
oh we like your voice i'm like oh
all right well thanks i guess because i
was so used to my voice being annoying
and kind of like
high pitched but maybe i started puberty
i don't know the answer in your 40s
maybe you have a good week
yeah i had an okay week that was your
week it was pretty good man i'm alive
i'm
i'm doing my gratitudes more trying to
be thankful for more stuff
um had a great conversation on instagram
live last week
with a kid uh zach a friend of mine his
dad's a friend of mine um they became
friends of mine i met him in a con and
he has a bionic arm he was born without
a limb wow and uh
he um writes a comic book called the
bionic kid and
he uh he's only 12 years old and what a
sensational young man he is and
great great family and so positive and
and just works really hard and um
there's this company called limitless
l-i-m-b-t l-i-m-b-i-t-l-e-s-s limitless
and you can donate and uh help is cause
they make um
they make it easy for people who need
bionic arms
that you know they don't want people to
pay so they could always use you to
use your donation so it's a great uh
place uh
i think it's limitless dot 3d or just go
on instagram to limitless with a b
limb mintless and uh i did this great
kind of
great conversation on instagram live
just with him for like 30 minutes and
just talked about him growing up and
if it's hard for him and how grateful he
is to have a bionic arm and
you know and he's just a pleasant kid it
was really nice to do usually i do
you know instagram lives to promote my
podcast
to promote the the band do something
funny and this felt like it was
something good and it was easy and
uh i loved talking to him so zack all my
love to you
great conversation you can find that on
my instagram at the michael rosenbaum
uh and thank you everyone for listening
um where can they
uh subscribe ryan they can subscribe on
apple podcast
spotify and youtube.com inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
and then of course the handles of uh
inside of you pod on twitter
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook
yeah so please subscribe follow us all
that
send 100 emails every week to all your
friends and make sure they subscribe
we could use your love thanks to all my
patrons out there
um big family now got a lot of patrons
uh
you can go to patreon.com inside
and join today i'll send you a message
after it's it's just like a big club
a club full of people who have a lot of
similarities and um
enjoy the podcast and uh they help it
out a little more
they um donate and sub you know
subscribe well donate i guess and uh
there's a bunch of added stuff you know
zooms and
uh merch boxes i send and all that stuff
so you guys know the ropes so
what's it called patreon.com inside
and thank you for uh supporting the band
sun spin if you want any merch like
lunch boxes hats
uh beanies coasters the the band is
sunspin you can see my logo shirt right
here
so sunspin you get these sweet shirts go
to sunspin.com you can book the band if
you want book of zoom
um and the inside eu store where you can
get tons of merch like lex autographs
lex luthor stuff flash stuff
lex luthor t-shirts which i'm almost out
of in fact uh a
lady ordered a small and we don't have
any so i have to now
be the bearer of bad news sorry i don't
have one i'm wearing it
no no um but uh thanks and that's uh
the inside of you online store and
there's always usually have um
discounts on there we had discounts the
last two weeks
so sweet also my buddy gave me this uh
bottle of vodka
it's pretty amazing it's uh p-a-p-o
papo joes papo j's popo jay's
lambonag vodka detailed 100
from a hundred percent coconut nectar in
the islands of the philippines papo
jay's lembonag vodka
so check that out he's uh he's just a
buddy um
pretty good weekend i i sometimes i just
find myself getting overwhelmed then i
take a deep breath and i say hey
things are okay and then i think oh well
you're not on the right meds or oh
you're on this i'm like
no you're just uh you know you're not
perfect dude
so go out for a walk have a workout
disconnect i'm trying i had
some good interviews this last week we
interviewed this one guy who really
talked about mental
uh illness and uh can't wait till he
airs um talks about having a
psychosis psychotic break and that was
interesting um
last week was richard speight and rob
benedict from supernatural
and uh you know we talk about rob having
a stroke and richard saving his life and
that's just a fascinating story so catch
up on that one
today's guest is uh he's become a friend
i think this guy's got a heart of stone
gold gold not stone jesus
uh precious stone precious precious
stone that's right what's a precious
stone
uh silver like uh like uh like a ruby
like an
opal oh you're thinking that stone yeah
that's what i was thinking
you're right you're right so i'm trying
to justify your slip up
yeah well we could just uh forget i said
it and stop dwelling on it
anyway you've seen him in goonies you've
seen him in rudy you've seen him in lord
of the rings this guy's been
everywhere but boy does he open up and i
just always enjoy talking to him and uh
you could you know watch this on video
and watch watch the wonderful shaun
aston he's uh he's a terrific man i
didn't know that but his dad is um
mr adams he was the original uh uh
what's his name mr adams the addams
family i mean that's as far as i know
too
yeah anyway why don't we waste no more
time and get into
sean astin it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
ladies and gentlemen sean aston is in a
studio do you have a studio at your
house dude
i'm in my daughter's bedroom what and
we've set up this little uh
i just recorded a book on tape and uh so
it was the it's the only room with dead
enough sound
so uh she's like dad what are you are
you i was like yeah no i'm doing a
podcast she goes
can i have my room back
yeah so you're in your daughter's
bedroom right now
yeah and is it a corner of her bedroom
is it like because i have these little
like
wardrobe stands with furniture pads on
them
but i'm so sick of zooms like
oh here's your backyard oh this is your
living room oh this is your whatever i'm
like you know what i just have this
thing set up i'm gonna do this like some
badass in a studio guy well it looks
like professional it looks like i mean
you know your mic's in the air you know
it's not just in front of you
yeah you got the sound sheets up the
blankets
you could be anywhere but i know there's
her little
oh look i'm not it's inappropriate for
me to show her room so i'm just gonna
it's completely inappropriate how are
you buddy i miss you
i'm so boring that's what i am i'm
boring now i miss you too you look you
haven't changed
debate covet hasn't hurt yet uh that's
not true i had knock on what i haven't
gotten covet but like i was just saying
today
uh ryan's like you look like [ __ ] i go
well you know i just got off these
meds that you know for you know some
anxiety stuff and i got off it and i'm
just a little dizzy
i'm like a little bit off and i just
took a big poop so that was cool
but so you're off like if you lay down
and then you sit up you're off
or no it's like all the time it's just
like you know when i turn my head it's
just it's a second of like it
it kind of comes back to me but it's
when did you when did you finish
uh two days ago so you know it's kind of
an abrupt thing it was just like a you
know i was on a low dose and it was just
like not working so i don't know how
everyone isn't on anxiety medicine
i mean she mean christmas this entire
planet
is anxiety inducing you know i mean
at this point helicopters go over the
house low and i'm like
jesus it's over the incoming is here
uh well i'm sorry that you had that uh
challenge but
you look from my side of things
badass as usual well thanks there's some
filters on no there's no filters
but like you know i know we've talked
about this in the past but like
i i i mean are you anxious are you
getting anxiety do you deal with it you
take any like uh xanax or anything
that's like cope with this
scheisse i haven't taken any um any
anxiety medicine i listen we're all
um the mental health
situation coming out of this pandemic
for every single human being
is something that has to be
addressed actively you can't i don't
think any of us
i mean i saw some show from the 80s we
were sitting watching tv which is like
what we do
and some show from the 80s came on and
there was a scene with a bunch of people
in it
and i literally had this feeling of like
being worried about the people in the
room like
all those people are in the same room
together that's not healthy that's not
safe you're like that's 1987.
so i mean i definitely my entire
consciousness has has been
you know re-configured or something so
yeah no i mean
we're it's we're hurting we're
absolutely hurting there's no question
about it when you say we're hurting your
family's hurting
yeah oh me my my friend my wife seems to
handle it the best
but each of the kids we have three
daughters yep
we all go through moments where you're
like what is wrong with you what's going
oh like wait a minute maybe if
it wasn't coveted for the last 12 months
this
moment of you know anxiety just says a
different word like what is anxiety
exactly you know
um we we got a um
a camper we haven't left
the house wait a minute you haven't left
the house since march
in a year no no no no come on you go to
the grocery store
no way everything gets delivered the
groceries get delivered on the steps
it's out there for a half hour we have
we my my girls all have um
asthma and they all get pneumonia really
easy and so their
their doctor early on was like you know
what you're in a hot you're not in a
high-risk
group my wife actually is because she
has a thing but um i don't know how much
i'm supposed to talk about with that but
the
the um they're like you you need to be
on the extreme end of cautious
so we we took that now and now
you know yeah so yeah i have anxiety now
we're like when do we when you go
outside every time i see people outside
i'm like oh my god what's going on with
them
the only time i've gone outside was our
car battery when the fires were
happening
i'm like if we have to evacuate because
of the fires we need to make sure the
cars are running
so i had to go out and jump start the
cars because the battery died and then i
would just drive around in circles
inside of our little gated community
you know for 25 30 minutes watching
people walking their dogs without mask
and being like
like they're vampires the people without
their mask on
um so yeah i mean and then we got a
camper
but uh i we had our former nanny and my
and who was sort of functioned like an
assistant for us really for a lot of
a lot of years was um happy to
greet the camper to when i say camper i
mean like
one of those teardrop fits one person
guy in yosemite who's gonna be rock
climbing
outdoor campers right like not like
i'm thinking of a big rv like a camper
no no no this is like pull behind
a you can pull behind a a car it's so
small you can lift it up and move it but
it's got like
you know all the stuff you'd want it's
got a stove a stove and a microwave and
a
bathroom and all that stuff all within
you know it's like the size of three
porta potties but in a teardrop shape
and we got it because the girls were
worried
and this was right when it was happening
this was like in may right during one of
the big
the first big peak i guess right and the
girls
we're worried like okay the last time we
had to evacuate the house
first we spent two days in a hotel and
then we have all these dogs
oh that's our instead of xanax we got a
puppy
that that calms your anxiety the puppy
well it completely takes
your attention away from everything and
they're so cute so but once that settles
you have to keep getting a puppy like
every six months
but what kind of what kind of puppy i go
crazy i have a two and a half year old
oh we this one is a king charles uh king
cavalier
king charles cavalier whatever it's
called kevlar king charles spaniel
and it is so cute he's like a she's like
a teenager now she's grown from this to
this and she's
uh my wife was up all night with her
last night because she must have eaten
like a piece of popcorn that she
shouldn't have had or something so that
wasn't that wasn't a pretty
pretty story but we have so we have like
we have a lot of we i can't even talk
about our dog situation but we have
that's our um
but the camper so it's small enough to
fit in the garage and we have like a
normal two-door
you know the we have two we have a
two-door and then one door so it's like
you know why such a small camper you got
three girls you got a wife you got dogs
you got
it's a bad decision is it bad
that's something bigger you got a little
money i mean you got three kids so i
don't know how much
but we just suck in your driveway where
are you going to put it in your driveway
in front of the house let people be oh
we live on a hill like this like yours
but like
three times as steep as yours like this
like if you drop a basketball
out of like you get out of the back and
you open up when a basketball falls out
you will kill a child on a tricycle at
the bottom of the hill it is
it ends up at the forum it is a steep
remember that bill cosby routine about
go-karts it's like
do you remember that comedy obviously
like his first or second comedy album
he did this hilarious thing about
go-karts i don't know maybe we're not
laughing right now but but anyway you
can laugh
at that now but we were we the whole
idea of it
listen this is like your anxiety
you managed it what do you mean i
managed i'm trying to manage it right
now
as i speak to you but think of the
absurdity
of how everyone is
thinking about things it's absolutely oh
yeah like i was watching the news today
sean
and i don't want to just throw you know
useless knowledge or like hearsay
but i did hear something like oh we know
that the vaccines last
at least three months i'm like i
literally from the other room go
what three months
was that what from the white house
briefing room was that for the cdp thing
was that
it was i think my biggest problem has
been you look at some of these other
countries
and they may not be 100
accurate with what they're saying but
they seem to be speaking with
one clear voice and in our freedom
loving country
there's no consistency in what you're
hearing partially because they're
learning
what's happening yes it's happening you
know don't wear masks you'll only wear
masks for other people oh yeah you got
to wear masks for yourself and
you know you you play them back to back
and you're like are these people
schizophrenic
or are they really learning something as
they go along
and and you and and not just that but
you know this this situation
was predictable and predicted
i mean have you seen contagion well
you've been just it's great for your
anxiety if you're watching
i'm not watching that [ __ ] i watched uh
greenland last night
my friend marina backroom was in this
movie greenland with gerard jeopard
no gerard butler not jeopardy totally
different
totally different guy completely
different noses
or was that steering out of the berger
body mass index
but i watched it and it was like this
these meteor fallings
falling out of the sky meteors and i
just was like ryan i was like holy crap
that gave me some anxiety right there
that was enough
you know that could happen you never
know you always hear yeah meteor is 400
million miles away it probably won't
strike earth
and no one gives a [ __ ] they're like oh
yeah whatever uh not listening i always
hear that there's a meteor that might
crash
tomorrow and then they and then it
passes by well we dodged a bullet with
that one and you're like
first of all why didn't you i want to
know in enough time to panic i don't
want to like have my
you don't rob me of
you don't want to know if it's happening
i want to know it's got to be like the
last second they're like
a meteor is expected to strike and it's
either that or they don't even tell you
because it's like the fear that it will
be instilled
upon us i think that will just everybody
will
run over each other and you know i
remember seeing um
i think it was sandra bullock on the
letterman show
and i think it was her it might have
been another uh another actress but i
think it was her
and her private jet
had some trouble when it was landing
like the landing gear messed up or there
was a flat tire when it landed
and there was skidding involved
and she's telling david letterman this
anecdote about what happened and he's
like my god well what were you thinking
are you okay
and she described it a little bit he's
like yeah but you seem so calm
and she goes well it's not happening now
yeah yeah that's true
like why let's let us calibrate
our our terror relative to the
timing of the threat so
we know like there's a lot that we know
and understand and we can
and this is where religion can can play
a useful role or jazz music can play a
useful role like
some people like you know what we're all
nobody's getting out of this
alive we're all you know what i mean if
we're lucky we live to 117 like that
lady
who just beat covet in france or
wherever i mean the queen is
the queen's almost a hundred margaret
lived till 100 and
something you know it's so it's
ridiculous yeah so so then we are
uh uh uh midlife at the moment if we're
and but the point is like
we've there was a moment when when lord
of the rings won best picture
that moment
i i was like i can well i feel like i've
made a contribution to the
to the world i feel like i've done like
if i die now
i can die at peace because i i did
something
and i think teachers and nurses nurses
and firefighters like if
whatever your thing is if you if you
live and it doesn't have to be epic you
know it's like
some people my wife i remember when we
first got together we were sitting in
the bathtub
with my gorgeous girlfriend at the time
and uh you know she was this uh
she's sexy and always still is of course
you're wait you're sitting in the
bathtub with your wife yes
obviously naked you know yeah we take
baths and naked okay i just wanted to
make sure because you never know
so thanks i'm just painting a picture
for you man we just had our fit our 30th
first date anniversary uh on the 13th
wow
yeah and you're going to be 50 in a week
and that'll be 50 is it a week yeah yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] buddy life
but you've already made a contribution
so who cares whatever you do
that's the thing well we were sitting we
were in this bathtub and
i was i proposed to her the first minute
i met her i was like
you know the fact that she even looked
twice at me was ridiculous like clearly
she had some mental defects because
you can't be that gorgeous and that's
stupid like
for me i'm like this [ __ ] actor guy
running around and uh
and and we're there and she's from
indiana her dad was a firefighter i grew
up in indiana
indiana's beautiful right and you know
but she was she was small town people
she was working actually in beverly
hills at the time
at a commercial agency that's how we met
but but her mentality
as sophisticated as she was she was like
real people
you know she's like a normal how so says
what she means means what she says
like you know does it can see uh
artifice
for what it is you know like enjoys
things that are exciting and and
you know whatever but but has a sense of
perspective about the world it's just a
world view
i know you know that that some people
have a way of a way of being a
settledness she came from a
a family like her mom died when she was
three
her dad cycled through a lot of
different women um
she uh there was there was a lot of
drama in her
early life and it just it just what came
out of that was a person who was like
you know what i
that can define me or i i can be me you
know what though what i just figured out
what you just said
her dad died when she was uh or her mom
died when she was three
her dad uh you know was a flanderer you
know with women coming in and out
and then my thought is then she sees you
and for some reason you're already in
the bathtub when she sees you
and she has she looks at you and says
this
because this guy you have a certain
disposition that gives comfort to people
you are comforting sean and i think that
that's a big part of let me am i wrong
she just felt like you are a humble uh
man
who could give her other things besides
pleasure
i think i was both a nurturing
type figure like a stable person because
i was all in from the second i met her
you know i mean there was no
how fast come on people say that but how
fast were you all in
five minutes five minutes maybe
you say maybe not her brother worked her
late brother
worked at the uh actually her late
brother carrington
that's he painted that oh wow that's his
painting he's a painter
um but he uh he worked down the hall
she worked in the celebrity side and he
worked in the uh what non-celebrity side
i don't know whatever but
um he came in like five minutes after we
met
and she said this is my brother
carrington and i stood up and said
carrington it's a pleasure to meet you
may have permission to marry your sister
and he she was just uh had broken up
with someone
that he did not like so he was like sure
just like that he just sold her out i'm
like damn he's kind of like
don't trust that guy now how many dates
before
you actually proposed uh not available
either that or it's just i someone
sticks with me for so long that i'm just
like
i don't know they're still around maybe
i should just marry this person if they
could put up with my [ __ ] i'm gonna
because i just watched uh this richard
pryor uh
documentary and this woman just kept i
mean this guy was not a great i mean
look
genius comedian one of the best but also
not a great guy
i mean you know there's some dark [ __ ]
and she
stood even if after he got burned even
after he got
i think ms or you know she stood
by him he says oh let's get married
she's like i mean i don't even know how
she said yes but she did
and uh i think he felt like wow
no matter what i do she sticks around
man she loves me that unconditionally
and there's something to be said about
that like you know they put up with your
[ __ ]
i think for me there's probably some
deep down childhood [ __ ] that i'm like
ah
i can't be loved i don't believe it
there's there's got to be ulterior
motives no one could love me
there's got to be that i know there is
and so
well i love you too but i think that
there has to come a time where you have
to say you know what i'm worthy
uh you know someone should love me but
you've always felt like
you could be loved you're a lovable guy
all right i'm telling you i love you i
haven't done an interview in a year
really well i mean i'm doing different
things but like
the reason we're doing this interview is
because there's something inside of you
some some pure thing that i that
means something to me and uh and of
course you're worthy of love of course
you are
you know a lot of times you feel like
some people like you're a
thoughtful guy and you're not just
thought you're an emotionally thoughtful
guy
and you're and sometimes you feel like
you wouldn't be
you know like you you would you wouldn't
be good for the other person you know
like you
like but you would but i feel like i'm
gonna let him down i always feel like
i'm gonna let you down
he let every we lady i let my wife down
so much it's just
awful i i honestly i'm like you let me
down with the camera with her for her
like i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry i am me and i'm yeah
no we always let each other down but
like with the richard pryor thing
there's something inside in particular
if you can see that thing inside
somebody else and other people can't see
it because
they're wowed by the spectacularity of
it all or they're
put off by the the you know the
grotesquery of all of it
but you see that thing in them and they
know you do and they see it in you
that that's there's something it's a
connection it's a soul
it's just it's a sound you know it is
but my what i said in the bathtub to my
wife was because i wanted to be
president of the united states i wanted
to be
the ceo of a billion dollar corporation
i wanted to be like david lean or some
filmmaker on
on some spectacular scale i i wanted
everything i wanted it all man
and so we're but this this girl was like
more important than any of that because
she was her and and i said
trying to negotiate our future
in the bathtub i said do you believe
that some people
are destined for greatness
and she said i believe you can be happy
having a simple life
and i was like [ __ ] i knew she's going
to say something like that jesus man
it's it's it's and so like some
somewhere when it comes to being afraid
of the things in this world that can
kill us
like you have to take care
you have to be cautious
but at a certain point you have to live
i mean that's what i'm going to be
trying to tell myself when it's time to
go back outside
this is a guy in a bunker talking
inside of you is brought to you by guy
co
it's geico folks it's geico you know the
word you know the term you know the
company
uh you know they they give good stuff
ryan they give good stuff
good bundles they got good bundling
policies here
long story short if you're tired of
paying auto insurance and
your rent or your mortgage which is a
pain in the arse to begin with
they have bundling policies and we're
busy we don't have time to pay all these
different people
uh we've got a lot going on and all you
have to do and they have great rates
guys
guy go has great rates just go to
geico.com it's so
simple you get a quote you see how much
you
could save it's geico easy visit
today that's geico.com
even a rosenbaum can do it inside of you
is brought to you by better help
better help online therapy listen guys
don't turn this off this is important uh
you know i've talked to many guests and
you hear about anxiety struggles you
hear about some guests uh
having mental breaks you hear about
depression you hear anger issues you
hear all these things
you deserve to be happy you deserve to
get therapy
and have someone to talk to i've been
doing therapy and it's been helping me
and i strongly suggest you guys it used
to be a stigma
not anymore i think the world is finally
maturing
and understanding how how important um
mental health is and being healthy
and uh look what is therapy exactly it's
it's what you want it to be it could be
anything you want
but it gives you the tools to help you
deal with all these things that we talk
about like anxiety and battling your
temper dealing with insecurity in
relationships
or at work whatever you need it's time
to stop being ashamed of normal
human struggles and start feeling better
because you
deserve to be happy i don't know how
many patrons have told me
from my patreon family that they've
joined better help and it's helped them
and it's a lot less expensive than
normal therapy you go to normal therapy
and you can spend
a crap ton of money and you don't need
to do that with better help online
therapy
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist
live chat sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you are your
greatest
asset this podcast is sponsored by
better help
and inside of you listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside betterhelp.com
inside
the most extreme thing no i think i felt
depression during this
but i think the most acute thing i've
felt and it's happened like five
times over the year is
um a claustrophobia a panic
associated with claustrophobia like
normally
i would think that i would be the kind
of person who'd go out and help with
um food distribution for people or
something something to contribute to
society i want to be
one of the those people and it's
probably good that i
like i'm probably lucky i didn't do that
but but uh because i'm like
heavy and like when you're there you
actually look good you i look at you
like you lost weight actually uh from
the time i saw you i did but
my pandemic i lost 30 pounds
i juiced and fitness and did all that in
the you know like on the treadmill and
in the backyard with jumping jacks and
in the sun all the time and in february
march
last year i was like
the pinup guy i always wanted to be i
remember
you were like really rocking it yeah and
then came
may and june and july and i hadn't eaten
any sugar
no refined sugar at all because it's
sugars my heroine
the until july and then the second i ate
sugar starting in july
catastrophic it was a catastrophe
there's a systems
i've been doing that sean i've been um i
never was a sweets guy
i was like i don't really buy sweets
i'll eat chips but i won't eat sweets
and all of a sudden the last few months
the whole girl scout cookie [ __ ]
you know people are like saying buy that
so i'm like of course i will and then
i'm not going to eat them i'll give them
away and then the mints you can't not
eat the mints
and then you got the peanut butter
cookies so you throw them in the [ __ ]
frizz freezer or fridge and they get
real hard it's the coconut ones though
nobody's gonna eat those no no the [ __ ]
no coconut but then all of a sudden
you're like going then i'm ordering um
postmating jamba juice smoothies
i'm like spending 18 to have something
delivered
i'm like what the hell are you doing and
it's like sugar city today was the first
day i had a trainer come he stood
outside the
garage outside and just told me what to
do and it was hard maybe that's why i'm
a little light-headed today but
uh it is it's it's did you eat food
yeah i did i had a big breakfast i had
eggs bacon and uh i cooked myself some
eggs bacon and toast
perfect workout food no i wouldn't say
well bacon probably not
what's wrong with pancakes protein but
but like right before you worked out no
right after
okay oh okay so you were carve loading
up or whatever well
yeah man i mean like i had a donut
and i had like you know like crepes and
i
i don't know why i feel like [ __ ]
i had positional vertigo once oh that is
all i know is vertigo is is the jimmy
stewart movie that
is is creepy that you can't look down
because you get like get dizzy
right so the there's a word that i
always
okay conical the conical inner ear like
it looks like it looks like a shell
deep in your inner ear they when you go
into the ear nose and throat they'll
show you a picture of like oh this is
your inner ear
if there sometimes this can happen to
people where you get a
tiny like tiny can't even see it with
the naked eye
piece of grit or something that lands
wrong in there
and it makes you dizzy i was doing a
thing where i'd be in the bed and i'd
sit up and my eyes would be going like
this
and i'm like oh my god i'm dying all
right lean forward and you feel like
this pressure in your head and you look
up and my eyes go
so i went to the doctor and they did all
these tests and they go you have
positional vertigo
i'm like what the you know how do i get
rid of it like is that well i said how
do you get rid of you goes
it's really actually it's kind of a
lifelong thing i've been experiencing it
for weeks like two weeks three weeks
i thought maybe it's maybe i have the
flu i don't know i don't know what i
thought it was but
you know i'm not like a race to the
doctor kind of guy back back then and
in my 20s and uh the second he said that
i never had it again well i may have had
it a couple times like in the last 30
years but
but i never but i was like there's no
way i'm gonna have that all the time so
i don't know if it was psychosomatic or
if i just dealt with it a little bit
better but
i don't know what the situation was but
for i always thought it could get me out
of um
like a dui positional vertigo
these tests of yours are not going to
work can you walk the straight line no
i've just told you i have something in
my
kill molecule what is that positional
vertigo
your honor what's the thing in your ear
the collicule the conical
conical the hairy genicle
right gotcha but i'm just saying like
the um so i know that dizzy sensation
but what i'm saying was the
the um the panic associated with
claustrophobia
because i would look outside and it was
literally we have a nice big home we're
very lucky we have a nice backyard we
can go in a pool and
lay out in the sun and like we're you
know if you're going to be in house
arrest somewhere this is where you'd
want to be in house arrest
that's nice you know but but at a
certain point i remember shaq
saying at one point when he lost a
championship
and uh like was it before kobe or with
i can't remember but he he was like it
doesn't matter how rich you are when you
lose
he's like you've got four walls and when
you win they seem like the biggest four
walls ever they go when you lose
it's just a [ __ ] wall you know you're
just staring at a wall and i remember
thinking like this
optical sensation that the walls were
like
wobbly like i'm not going to be able to
leave like i'm not leave what happens if
i can never leave again what if
you know this was before they talked
about variants and stuff too this was
like
this is like what if it lasts forever
what if you know and then you watch
shows like last man on earth
yeah i've seen it yeah oh it's great oh
my god he's so
great in that show he kind of makes it
like it wouldn't be that bad to be the
last person on earth i guess but
anyhow i that that sensation all of the
like
layers of emotional and psychological
stuff that come along with this
i think we all have to address ourselves
to
being patient and realizing that
it is going to take time for us to learn
how to
human again how to be with people
well yeah well what's scary is well
doesn't it scare you i guess not you're
the kind of person that they say you
have situational vertigo and then the
next day you're like [ __ ] no i don't
you know i don't have that and then it
goes away so it may be a stupid question
but you know obviously
we talked about your incredibly famous
mother patty duke
the late patty duke god rest her soul
and she suffered from mental illness in
fact there's a
organization uh the mental health what
is it called
patty duke foundation the patty duke
mental health organization which finally
is making its first
expenditure of money over she died five
years ago almost six years ago
and uh well just about almost exactly
six years ago
at the end of next month it'll be six
years the uh we we've just been holding
the money because we raised a bunch of
money but it wasn't enough to do
to like start a foundation the way we
wanted to so now
connected with um coming out of covid
we're
we're uh sponsoring or we're trying to
help
take um this charity that does
um it's a running charity and and it's
for kids elementary school kids
and it's it's it's a charity that i
started
uh and it's been self-sustaining but at
this moment because of covid
it's it's gonna have a dip so we've
actually figured out a couple of things
that we can do
and because kids need
um it's called run third is my charity
that i started and it's my idea that i
started and then mindy really started
the actual charity
but it it provides an after-school
running program for elementary school
kids in underserved areas and
the the run third is i run first for
myself
so we're teaching the kids about
self-empowerment there's a whole
curriculum
i run second for my family so it's about
connecting them with their family and
giving their their family a way to
connect with them
uh associated with with this running
kind of experience they're having
right and the third is i run third for
others
and so it's a hashtag run3rd it's when i
in 2010 11 12 somewhere like that
i started this thing and it becomes like
a living prayer chain on the hashtag
and we've got it it's in 12 it's in 13
schools
10 or 11 in mesa and then one in
arkansas and one in
massachusetts and so it's it's
it's having a dip at the moment because
there's they can't do the normal
fundraising they do and
there's a 5k at the end so these kids
imagine a
fourth fifth grade kid they don't do you
know most of them don't run
5ks but you you basically give them this
little curriculum and you coach them and
you give them an asterisk kids are happy
to do whatever you do if you spend time
with them
so we we provide this after school
experience with them and they
at the end of it it culminates with them
doing this 5k
run and they put on their back the sign
of the run third who they're running for
so that's great and they the kids are
like they're so happy and they're so
proud and they're
they're so alive when they come through
it and it's it's a selfless thing
they're dedicating their run
so to speak to to other people and so
the patty duke mental health
that money that i've parked in nowhere
waiting for something to
invested in we're going to support this
because coming out of covid
kids are going to need structure they're
going to need fitness they're gonna need
some way to orient to the world and i
think it's actually a really good
um application of that uh and the funny
thing was right the day after my mom
was the day after she passed her the day
after her funeral it was like the day i
can't remember it was
it was like a couple days after she
passed her something that i went to our
5k
so i went from idaho where my mom lived
down to mesa arizona
where the 5k was and people were there's
condolences and
it was it was a whole thing and so i
don't know i feel like there's a tie in
a tie in there but um um
what the [ __ ] was your question well no
i mean look it wasn't really a question
it was like talking about
your mom and talking about the
foundation and after she passed
and mental health but really the
question is
did you ever worry because it seems like
someone you're not someone that would i
would worry
that maybe bipolar manic depressive
they're both the same thing utterly
right i mean
um oh if you opened up the diagnostic
you know there's the that manual this
big i can never
remember that it's it's the pd something
i can't remember what it's a
diagnostic manual for all mental illness
if you open it up
and i'm sure this is true for a lot of
people but if you look you know i am
sure that i satisfy
a great number of the criteria that
would be listed on it so
the good you know we talked about my
wife
the to have a partner
in managing
my mental life is uh
a gift from god really and then you know
yeah it's just very aware of
me and my life and my history and
just keeps keeps an eye keeps an eye
and then the other thing i was saying
was that we have kids and it is a
hereditary
uh situation you know the thing about
the conical thing just going back for a
second about doctors
here they are not very iconic
very conical they're going to go i want
to say something about that diagnosis
their jobs doctors jobs are
uh constantly under threat of like
the liability that they live under
everything they say
could ruin their career their practice
their financial life
their kids fortune so doctors
generally will lean on a more
severe interpretation of what uh you
know
uh uh you know um just they they give
you a harder diagnosis than
so cover the bases yeah but i mean
you're like well it's a permanent thing
well it wasn't permanent
but you know what i can never say to the
guy after five years you never said that
it was still gonna be with me after you
misrepresented right you said something
you said it would go away how many girls
do you know who are like i was told i
could never have children
yeah true right right well people like
you you'll never walk again
right when they walk right if anything
it gives you uh
what's the word ambition or or no not
hope i mean
that would be a hopeless thing to hear i
mean you never
walk again i thought you meant the idea
that they're not true all they can give
you but no yes no they give you
determination determination yeah
determination i mean that's really where
people decide who they are
like sure how are you going to receive
such a harsh
uh diagnosis but i think with mental
illness
you know my mom's mental illness her
thing was
use her diagnosis as a
i think we talked about this last time
but um
as an identity like
who are you are you the person who
behaved badly
on a few sets and in relationships and
had a reputation
for being volatile or are you a person
who is
a champion for something that you've
overcome
so she chose she chose that one so wow
we all pick what we want our
narrative to be what we want our
relationship to the public to be
and um so i've always engaged the mental
health
bipolar discussion from the point of
view of someone who grew up from a
family member
as a family member survivor in a way
right
you know that's a word yeah sure i don't
like that word for me i don't like it
for me but i certainly understand it
um um i mean that word is we're very
aware of that word in modern culture
right now because of
the kind of the women's movement you
know has
advanced so significantly in the past
few years um and being a survivor is
like a new
it's a new vote it's a new word in the
it's not a new word but it's gained real
currency
lately so i wouldn't use it for me in
with my mom sense but yeah i mean
it's i think it probably is appropriate
because you know it's
it was there was like we talked about it
it was it was hard there were really
really really hard painful tragic
violent
like bad times as a as a as a kid but no
what i'm i'm just saying
like i've i haven't wanted to talk about
uh bipolar relative
to me personally i haven't wanted to say
like that's my identity
that's who i am that's my experience
i've been more than happy to
because my mother for herself
chose to make her experience her
diagnosis her recovery her
advocacy she made that a very
public thing she wrote books she made a
movie she was she was on talk shows i
mean it was her
her raison d'etre you know it's why it's
who she was it's what she wanted her
legacy
to be i i don't want or need that to be
my legacy what i
what i'm happy to do is travel around
the country
and speak to groups about by
bipolar disorder um from the perspective
of a family member
but you know anybody who knows me who
who's experienced me in my life is like
oh okay you know wait wait wait wait
wait when you say
okay are you saying okay as if you might
not that you diagnose yourself but when
you read about things you think
there's a good chance that i probably
have it and i'm working on it and it's a
constant battle and something you don't
really talk about
sort of i mean uh any commercial i see
on tv for any ailment i'm sure i have
that ailment
we could always do that i'm like oh my
god my hair
i'm sure i haven't oh my god
fibromyalgia
is let me tell you that thing is always
on cnn
they must pay if they would just not do
ads they'd probably save
millions of dollars but honestly i i
look at the fibromyalgia and i look at
it and i go
fatigue constant fatigue i'm like oh my
god i i got the fajalja
inside of you is brought to you by hello
fresh
boy do they make eating healthy
easy i am tired of ordering food and
spending so much money ryan
that's all i do is use these apps and i
spend i'm like how did i spend this much
money
uh ordering food it's so easy because
we're not going anywhere
but you could save so much money with
hellofresh by just
they give you the pre-measured
ingredients mouth-watering recipes
delivered right to your door you skip
the trips to the grocery store
and you can count on hellofresh to make
some good home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit i don't have to tell you if
it's america's number one meal kit
hellofresh offers 25 plus recipes to
choose from each week from vegetarian
meals to craft burgers and extra special
gourmet options
there's something for everyone to enjoy
with all recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs
and nutritional experts to ensure
deliciousness and simplicity
and you get better value hellofresh is
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store 72
cheaper than a restaurant meal without
sacrificing
the quality and that's a zagat dining
survey in case you're wondering where i
got that information i personally love
uh
getting the ingredients and making
myself a nice dinner
and not having to worry about what i
need to put into it and how do i make it
tastier and how much of this
they give you all the ingredients
everything you need is in the box i make
a nice chicken meal
and uh i've got i had this plum
chicken or something once and it was
just delicious and i was like i can't
make this
of course you can it's right there in
front of you you got the ingredients
you got your skillet you just do it it's
so freaking easy guys
and uh it's healthy and you know you
want to get yourself
started this year doing something
healthy for yourself i know everybody's
trying to exercise and it seems so
daunting
but making a meal for yourself and
saving some money sounds like a pretty
good way to start things out um
especially if you're gonna get on the
health train go to hellofresh.com
12 iou and use the code 12
iou for 12 free meals
including free shipping
hellofresh.com 12 iou and use the code
12 iou
for 12 free meals including free
shipping and just know that hellofresh
is america's number one meal kit
inside of you is brought to you by keeps
do you know ryan two of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 years old more than 50
million men in the u.s suffer from male
pattern baldness
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
keeps offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door
every three months you don't have to
even leave your home hello
treatments start at just ten dollars a
month and keeps offers generic versions
discreet packaging and proven results
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors
that's right prevention is key folks
treatments can take four to six months
to see results
so act fast act now you know ryan i have
so many friends who are losing their
hair uh
guys girls and i'm like well why don't
you
well i don't know just what can you do
i'm like
you could do lots of things i mean for
one you can go to keeps
it's fda approved and you could give it
a shot
and see if this stuff works apparently
it does if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash inside of you to receive your
first month of treatment for
free that's keeps keps dot com
slash inside of you to get your first
month
free keeps.com slash
inside of you what i'm saying for me
is that that's not a diagnosis
that i want to make a part of my
identity i hear you i don't
no i'm just yeah so and you know what
the
it's funny because i talk in a lot of
these um
uh talks that i do i mean i just gave a
mental health talk to uh
the american correctional association
that's like 1500
uh uh correctional officers right and
talking about my mom's experience
talking about my experience growing up
offering my perspective and thoughts
about things and
and one of the things that i talk about
is
language and how and
and and and how language is i mean the
mental health field the psychiatry in
particular
uh has come so far i mean my mom's thing
was we have to destigmatize
and you even see it now that nfl
football ad was so great about
you know destigmatizing it and
everything else but in a um not but also
in a way that project of destigmatizing
has worked in a lot of areas maybe not
in all areas but
you know if you go to if you go to
indiana where my wife is from
people are more than comfortable talking
about their medications
you know and oh i've got to go to cvs to
get my medication oh i have and and
somehow
it's like it's a little bit more
socially acceptable
now for people to use that phrase and
that should be encouraging to anybody
who
has an issue that like oh there's a lot
of places in this world you can go
where you are uh where where
where someone with that diagnosis is
fully understood and accepted to be
a total human being and it's not going
to uh
limit your your life and that's exciting
that's exciting it's thrilling but the
vocabulary of psychiatry
actually in a lot of ways is meant to be
used between
physicians and between physicians and
the drug world in pharmaceutical world
and the nursing community and
administrative people
and there's a lot of people for whom the
the vocabulary of mental illness
is really efficient and
you know proper and throwing everything
but it totally [ __ ] up a lot of people
you know actual human beings who are
actually being diagnosed because
in a lot of ways it's like uh it's like
a death sentence
for people it feels like a brand like
branding you know it's like this is this
you're labeled this is who you are
well that but also just just
you know they they uh they call one of
the words is uh
well patient your mental health patient
but you're also
uh they use the word sufferer oh this
person's a mental health sufferer
and you're like jesus christ how's
anybody supposed to develop
like wellness in their life if they're
constantly thinking of themselves
indefinitely as a patient or
indefinitely as
a sufferer like that vocabulary is not
helpful
that people do sufferer is not something
people want to
associate themselves with oh i am a
survivor and recovery
and like those words can be very very
helpful
and very empowering and very useful
and particularly certain phases of
people's uh
discovery of their own like wellness
strategy
but um but for a lot of people it makes
it so they don't want to get it
diagnosed they don't want to go to the
doctor they don't want to
consider uh the types of medications
that might be available to them they
don't
they don't want to consider it because
they just don't like the vibe
and to me the community can do itself a
big service by acknowledging that
its communication skills are
like the lagging
thing in their progress and so what i
was saying was in terms of stigma
it actually is still there in a way like
in in
if you have your druthers pick that
diagonal you know talk about that
diagnosis or not
um i get a lot of positive feedback when
i say to people when they ask me what
you're asking me
like you don't have to and relative to
my kids relative to anybody
you don't have to tell anyone
what your diagnosis is
you know first thing the willingness the
bravery it takes to
to put yourself up for some kind of
evaluation to see if if some sort of
diagnosis is
you know appropriate for you that takes
courage it's terrifying for people to do
that
um and then but doing that and then
getting the diagnosis
that's just the doctor's half of the
equation you have to accept
the diagnosis and if you're willing you
know
if the diagnosis isn't right for you and
you don't accept it you know
good for you that you went through a
process where you are more
armed with information than you were
beforehand if you get a diagnosis
and you're willing to accept it because
it's helpful to you
uh then that's great too yeah but
then when it comes time to sharing your
process and your
experience some people aren't like us
some people
don't feel good some people's work
environment for example
is not conducive if you were to you know
you may be legally protected
but it might make people uncomfortable
because they have some
who knows what so you people have to
decide for themselves
if and when they seek a diagnosis they
get a diagnosis they accept a diagnosis
and they share a diagnosis
each one of those things guess who's in
charge
the guess who's the boss of each one of
those moments
you you're the boss of your moment you
get to say
whether you're gonna go get a diet
unless you you know you find yourself
uh in that situation because of
circumstances that you're unable to
control but
but um but choosing to get a diagnosis
getting the diet and by the way it takes
a lot of people it's
much much faster now i don't know what
the the newest statistics are with the
psychiatric institute of america or
whoever
uh i'm sure it's within like 18 months
or something like that but
that's just me spitballing but it used
to be when my mom was alive when she was
in in the mid 80s it would take like
eight years
to get an accurate diagnosis eight years
my god of suffering yeah
and you know by the way doctors can be
[ __ ]
you know doctors can be and you you
never want to um
push away the possibility that someone
could get help from a physician
or a psychiatric professional but
they've come a long way too
they used to be real [ __ ] like as a
class maybe not
totally maybe i was insulated from it
but my experience of
people was that they were so arrogant
and condescending
and dismissive and un you know uh
unpleasant unsupportive yeah unless it
was in their way
you know and and now i've seen i've seen
physicians by and large now
what i've been exposed to and it's
anecdotal so
people have to make up their own minds
and choose their own thing but
like there is some humility that has
worked its way into the system perhaps
because now
people don't have the same their
education the physicians their education
um there's so much that they don't know
and that they don't understand
and it's obvious to anyone that they
don't know and they don't understand it
that it's like well this is what we do
know this is what we do understand and
we want to help you with this
but there's a lot of stuff we don't know
so i find that humility when it's
expressed by physicians
terribly reassuring because i'd much
rather have somebody tell me
that they don't uh that they don't know
something rather than
hedge or fudge or use their personality
or intimidation or something like that
um you know to to compel me to do
something
or to obfuscate the fact that they
aren't on 100 sure footing with what
they're saying you're on point today
you're very passionate and fiery about
this and i like it because you're
passionate
very passionate about it and i really i
appreciate that listen this is called
uh [ __ ] talking with sean astin i like
that kind of wrong
goes with your name [ __ ] talking with
sean astin my wife would concur
these are questions from my patrons uh
rapid fire
or you know if you really want to uh go
a little longer feel free but it's rapid
fire sophie m if you could have
50 50 first dates which i know you were
in
what would your ideal date be to do over
and over sit in the bathtub with your
wife
that's where i went that's right where i
went that's where i went with your wife
i mean with you and your wife this is
true before
uh kovid's uh missing year
um oh there's something else i want to
share with you but um
uh a date you do what would your ideal
date be to do over
and over i guess that you know uh
honestly there's a place we go in hawaii
and uh we can either take our little
golf cart or we can walk down to where
the uh
the the beachside
grill is and uh and we sit there and
have a little a little drink and yeah
just walking
walking together sun sun kissed and
walking down
to the you know at at sunset
you just got warm and fuzzy
they're so bad right now i'm going to
make it i'm like we're going away you're
going to go either in the bathtub or the
y maybe just take the bathtub there's a
bathtub in hawaii just so you know
probably there's one other thing i want
to tell you yeah go ahead so kovid
there's like epochs the guitar
period i got better at the guitar not
enough i thought about bringing it in
here but not enough to bring it in here
something thank you wait hold on
oh yeah
hey mr tambourine man play a song for me
i'm not sleepy and there's no place that
i'm going to
hey mr tambourine man
play a song for me honey i love it
though it's sweet i
you know you you enjoy it i could see
you enjoy playing guitar you keep doing
it
play more but um um um um
uh so there was that then my union got
into a uh there was a whole thing with
uh stuff going on with the union
business
and i got deeply invested in that for a
couple months and then
oh look at this what happened the dog's
here guys
here oh my gosh look at that little
monster
look at those ears what's her name
what's her name again
holly holly you didn't know her name i
know her name
dad's one of our tricks is to make it
like we're stupid
and so they're like oh he's just
pretending he's stupid and then when we
really are stupid which is most of the
time it can't tell the difference
okay next question lisa h in encino
man what was it like to work with paulie
shore honestly
and any thoughts were teaming up to make
it an encino man 2
the older years we have all indicated
that we would be more than happy to do a
sequel
um personally i want to know what betty
nuggs looks like
30 years later that was one of the that
was a cave girl that came up at the end
of the movie
i remember what about paulie paulie was
really focused
uh really knew his audience he was
really kind of
had a sweet spot in his life in his
career um
where he
he he was he was ambitious
he was kind of like the opposite of his
character
so wait so he didn't talk to you in off
camera like
hey shaunie what's up bog
what are you doing today bob he was just
very protective
of the fact that he had his hit mtv show
and this thing was going on and he
didn't want
he was just protective of it so no he
would talk to me but we didn't get on
that great
um because i didn't really want to be
doing the movie wait you didn't get
along that great
well i mean whatever we got i mean it
wasn't like there wasn't any bad
anything but he
knew he didn't want to do it so there
was a little bit like uh he didn't even
want to be here
no i was kind of like i had done some
movies
that were substantial movies right like
what besides
goonies and rudy and uh i did memphis
spell and they're not
substantial in red like history on the
historical weapon
but memphis bell was a movie that i did
that was i think kind of an important
movie it was uh
uh kind of a love letter to veterans of
the the air war in europe and
um it was david putnam you know who did
chariots of fire and
and the mission it was a very memorable
movie but he but you didn't
it took a lot to get you to do this
scheduling and you weren't as passionate
so there probably was a little bit of
animosity or whatever i get it
right not animosity just be like how i
throw that word at you
i just threw it out like you're like
yeah oh yeah
like we just we just were like on
different pages
but like like brendan fraser and i would
play video games in the
dressing room awesome we'd be like and
cut and we'd run to the dressing room
and go in the dressing room and play a
video game
you know like we were we bonded like
that um
later in life and times paulie and i
i think like we i we like each other
like we're we're i think we'd be happy
to be
interacting together and i think i my i
appreciated
who he was and what he was doing at that
time but it just was not my scene
i'm just not the like guy who's gonna
like play a bunch of college campuses
and
you know talk about you know just be
hitting on all kinds of girls and
i don't know it just wasn't my it just
wasn't my vibe but i got why it was
why he had the audience i got why it was
fun and funny right
for him i just was it was me i was the
problem
maddie s you've had an awesome career
playing the underdog morally good
characters if you could choose
what type and or characteristics of a
villain would you love to
portray on screen um maybe the
vulnerability
you know it's a really weird thing when
someone can kill people
and yet they're you're like you feel for
them
you're like wow that's coming from a
place of pain you know because mostly
you just think like
shoot that person and get them out of
society right but if you're if you're uh
if you're an actor and you're studying
like what goes into
a villain i mean i don't know i don't
know maybe
i don't know that's just the first thing
that occurs to me is that
you know most actors who play villains
tell you that they've got to find a way
to find something about them
to connect with and
uh and i think that vulnerability that
sense of
or or or um injustice
i'm like a i'm like an injustice-a-holic
if i see injustice anywhere it makes me
so upset
makes me so even like a kid getting
bullied or the country getting bullied
or whatever it is i it just it just
makes my blood boil
and i so you know to have a baddie who
would
feel a righteous sense of indignation
and like they're doing what they're
doing because
they were wronged and they feel like
it's the right thing to do i don't know
and then you know usually there's some
grotesque perversion inside of them that
just makes them a villain but
rosie rosie asks this
you always play great roles sweet roles
guys you like have you ever worked with
anyone
that really bothered you that was hard
to work with
difficult to work with and that was
volatile on set
there's one actor who
there's only one time i ever walked off
a set
like i'm a professional my mother was a
professional
you know she she taught me at eight
years old
and 10 years old you know how to hit
your mark
and can know where your light is and
know your lines
and be better for the other person off
camera than you you are on kim and
you're on camera like
just the kind of nobility of
professionalism and that's that's what
i've always
uh it's always been in my soul even when
i even when i'm cocky i still think i
have that somewhere but
but uh there was this one actor who was
playing this like tortured angry person
and there was a scene where there's a
group of people on one
side and that person on the other side i
don't want to describe it too
specifically but
um the person
with a prop they they used the prop
violently too much like they were not
careful the things shattered and could
have gone in
people's eyes and it was like
unprofessional and i walked over to the
director and i just whispered to the
director you better handle that
and the director looked at me like
like i don't understand what you're
saying i was like did you just see what
happened
he goes yeah i said are you gonna
address that and he goes i think it's
great
stuff i said bye and i walked out
and he chased me down the street to the
thing and and he said i don't understand
i don't understand
i said what just happened was unsafe i
was like in order to work
in an environment it has to be safe i
was like so instead of punching in the
[ __ ] face
i decided to walk away and let you
continue your unsafe behavior without me
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i didn't
understand i didn't did you see a break
yes
did was it planned to be broken no could
that chip have hit that person in the
face
well could it yeah i guess it could have
yes did you ask that person if they felt
that could have gone in their face
uh go ask them if they thought that
could if they were scared
there's we're actors you know there's
there's a way in which
we are you know our fear we tap into
genuine fear
for it to work but the kind of fear that
comes from
you know an out-of-control actor
breaking something and almost injuring
somebody
is uh not okay so i walked out well that
actor came out
sobbing and so upset and and uh so i
ended up sitting
hugging the actor and talking through so
it worked out
it worked out at the end it was just a
big it worked out we went back in there
so
that's not exactly like you know was
there some human being i'm sure there
have been human beings that i was like
not that
much a fan of them as a human being but
but that's the thought that came into my
mind wow wait i have to tell you this
other thing
the third epoch the guitar epoch
okay union epoch i got into grad school
for six months i've been studying public
policy
and uh public administration at american
university online
what are you taking classes and getting
grades
are you doing well so far but this
interview's putting me behind so
no i want a dick
i love it no yeah no i'm doing well it
is the heart it is
incredibly hard it's much much much much
harder than i ever thought it would be
my my brain is constantly being just
bent in ways i didn't
i mean one class was uh um
administrative law i did two months of
administrative law
reading probably 120 cases of uh supreme
court decisions
oh my god like wow and writing about it
and then studying
you know all about cbs rapids 1973.
it's something i've always wanted to do
it's something i don't think i probably
ever
the only time i ever got close was when
i was doing stranger things
i had such a small part in it that i was
um
i was studying for the gre like at my
hotel room
day after day after day waiting to go to
work for 10 minutes
and uh and then i got a job that took me
out of the country and i couldn't
i didn't fall through with it so this
actually in a way the pandemic has
provided an opportunity for me that is a
lifelong dream
dude i'm proud of you that's awesome i
could see how happy you are doing
it which makes me incredibly happy all
right this is it man
this is these are rapid now you just
answer them quickly here we go last few
uh [ __ ] talking with sean astin leanne
when my brother was 18 he was diagnosed
with bipolar
disorder i had no idea what that was i
read your mom's book a brilliant madness
really helped me gain perspective and
understand my brother
and his struggles a little better so
that was just a statement thanking you
well yeah amen i thank her too
i've had so many people say the same
thing to me the big this isn't rapid
fire but the biggest one was
at a nursing home where my uh retirement
home i guess
um where my wife's grandfather was we
went to visit him when i came out of his
room
this nurse saw me barely any time to
register who who it was the human that
was in front of her
but she locked eyes on me and then she
almost
like physically collapsed and i had to
like grab her
so i was like holding her up like your
knees are shaking trying to hold this
lady up
and uh she's sobbing and she basically
said the same thing
that that she just said i answered uh
was it leanne who was indiana
yeah so um where it was her father who
was suicidal and
and he had a crush on my mom on her tv
show in the 60s and he gave her
gave him her book and he read the book
in one sitting and stood up and said i
don't i want to live
i want to live now so but you know that
book was a in our family
it was this the cause of a lot of uh
sturman drang is that the word the
german word there's a lot of hassle
i'm a jew i don't know if that's true
i'm not happy dad was not happy
it was it was there's a lot of stuff in
it that people didn't like
um but then over time that
pain from inside the family kind of went
away and this is the legacy of that book
is it helps people which is amazing
maya p rapid fire what's your proudest
moment as an
actor the one moment that pops in your
head when when they got best picture
lord of the rings was that it
yeah on the volcano in the lord of the
rings yeah
yeah well that was a lot a lot went into
that moment but yeah i mean like a
lifetime went into that moment but
as the as a you know i also the root
movement of rudy where rudy gets uh
accepted into notre dame
that was a huge breakthrough for me huge
breakthrough if it wasn't for that then
the
lord of the rings moment would not have
been the same
beautiful mary b your last visit inside
of you really touched my soul people say
that nice guys can't make it in
hollywood
you seem nice enough how do you keep
balanced how do you keep from straying
from your moral center
and you've answered that in so many ways
so in one sentence how could you sum
that up
uh you gotta know your way back
to your walls to your moral center
everybody
nobody lives pinned in a
moral certainty so my wife
i love it shows me the way back to it
find your way back
find your way back to your heart
do you know that song uh yeah there's
another song that has
one of my favorite songs on this thing
go on you have one more question right
uh yeah i mean what you do to stay a
positive ray h i mean
you know obviously you know you're with
your family you're doing this new thing
online and
uh doing something you've loved so it
kind of you kind of answered that one
my wife has this philosophy you know her
knee she has a knee
problem she's needed a knee surgery
maybe a full knee replacement
since before covid so her entire coved
has been limping
and but she says that she makes a
conscious decision and i've seen her do
this
there's times you know imagine she's got
four kids or three daughters and me
and dogs lots of dogs and it's like
she is she's the gravity she's the
center of gravity for our family
and uh but it's not always easy and it's
not always fun
uh and she you know the help she gives
to the girls with their homework with
their
studies their online studies um is
incredible and she says that she makes a
conscious decision
in the morning when she puts her feet on
the ground it's gonna be a good day
that is very important there's many
times where i just go hey
i have these little signs next to my bed
that says breathe it's okay
life's good you only get one let's go
[ __ ] it i'm with
i'm withdrawing your privilege of having
anxiety
for one year you're saying that i can't
you're not a lot you can have a little
bit of anxiety
but when you reach a certain ceiling of
it sean is there going
it's not today you know you know what
i'll probably think of that now
i'll probably think oh you're getting
anxious i'm like no sean wouldn't allow
that
you're allowed to be who you want to be
but i just
you are such you're not
so good dude and anybody who has a soul
that's as good as yours deserves not to
have
an unreasonable amount of stress and
anxiety i'm working
and look i love you for saying that and
i really do and i respect you and i i
miss you and
i uh i'm working on it man sometimes
things just
happen and you're you're so overwhelmed
by them that you don't know where to
begin again
and you feel like you're going it's the
same [ __ ] it's the same routine it's the
same
you know it's just part of like this is
what you do dude this is what you do
wait a minute wait a minute you might
have just found a the path to your own
salvation there
you just said you don't know where to go
to begin again
where can you go to begin again
what's a reliable place for you to go to
begin again
if you can figure that out and everyone
gets overwhelmed
everyone has you know problems and
whatever but at the moment where you go
like wait i gotta know where to go again
have a place you know what that's
brilliant that is brilliant i'm gonna
find that place because
ah let me tell you something man this is
the end of this podcast but
i will say i feel better than i did when
we started i felt like i don't know if i
could do this
i'm really not in the mood i'm a little
lightheaded i just feel tired
a little you know whatever you know i
get in my head
i i just felt like [ __ ] and then after
talking to you for 30 minutes the first
i completely had a shift did you notice
my shift ryan
it just if you watch this video again
you'll see the shift from
because you comfort me man i love you
man i love you too
hey give me a little made up dizzy is
you just have to
feel like a jazz musician go with it you
just have to feel like it's interesting
hey real quick play an end outro two
this was inside of you with michael
rosenbaum podcast
with sean asks just make up something
this was inside of you
this was inside
of you
well that's the one i did last time
i like that this has been inside of you
hey listen i love you and i can't thank
you enough for coming on again will you
come on once a year
yeah once a year man i'm your man listen
when this is all over when i'm allowed
to your house i want to come and just
hang out and meet the family i really
haven't got a chance to the uh the mars
pod
like i feel like we're living in one of
those biodomes that they set up like can
the astronauts survive for a year
in the yeah so come on out to our dome
see there may just be bodies it may not
even be
that sounds appealing all right i love
you buddy thanks for allowing me to be
inside of you again
love you brother all my love to your
family and keep doing that course i love
that you're doing that
i'm going to get a degree baby i'm going
to get a master's degree
i just what can you say about this guy
that hasn't been said
i mean he's just he's done it all he's
he's uh then he's off
what a career seriously and he just
stays so humble and sweet
i was looking over here because this is
where the rudy poster used to be oh yeah
the rudy poster but then i turned it
into horror movie posters now
well it you got a theme which is fine
yeah
yeah yeah that's where if you check it
out on youtube you'll see that i have a
lost boys original poster signed by um
kiefer and and jason and evil dead
signed by uh
uh bruce campbell and the fright night
poster some of the director tom holland
i just love movies and love horror and
some people make fun of me for having
these things but
kurt russell signed my the thing and
escape from new york posters
aliens posters signed by the cast i
think these are cool things you may not
you may think you are a door crossing
bomb but you know what
you're jealous that's it we're all just
totally jealous we're all just jealous
uh once again if you want to listen to
my band the album just came out i really
do think you're gonna like it if it was
crappy i would not tell you to listen
but you can get the cd and you can get
uh uh a lot of other great stuff beanies
trucker hats lunch boxes coasters
on the sunspin.com um
website that's correct and uh you could
also get all the amazing inside of you
with michael rosenbaum uh pictures from
inside of you like a rose and bomb or
lex luthor pictures flash pictures even
sorority boys pictures
they can get all this stuff at the
inside of you online store
lex shirts there's just so much great
stuff out there so i mean if you think
that stuff's great
i want to say thank you again for
listening and please subscribe as ryan
told you you know the handles
um if you listen to the beginning i
don't think you're going to start
listening to this podcast at the end
so uh always looking for more uh people
so if you
if you like this podcast tell a friend
and um
have them listen if you were here for uh
shawn aston hopefully he'll come back
next week for
whoever it is we're trying to get uh
bigger and
bigger guests and that is always what
we're striving good guests i should say
we're just trying to get good guests
at the end of the day you want a good
guest i'd rather have a good guest than
a big guest when you
yeah but you seem to you you've done a
good job especially lately of like
getting getting it out like if if
there's ever any doubt
in anyone's mind that like oh you know
you you find the angle and you get in
and you really do
they're all good episodes thanks ryan
yeah well thank you
and you edit them and that means that
means a lot yeah i tried to
again uh i tried to think like just
regular human beings
not like some actor going hey let's i
just really try to ask questions that
i'm interested in kind of go down the
little rabbit
holes of well you start there and then
it always ends up with the human story i
mean
i hope yeah that's the goal so keep
listening you get there listen to ryan
will you listen to the boy it always
happens
yes the goods are in there they're
always in there the goods are in there
goods well i i appreciate that i
appreciate all the letters that you guys
write me on hello insidetoupodcast.com
um they're awesome i read them all the
time if i don't respond to you
i just i don't respond to everybody i
can't possibly but
i read them and i'm touched by them so
if you want to leave any messages
hello at insideoutpodcast.com i believe
it is
and you leave messages there sometimes
people say oh i just made an
order but uh i gave the wrong address
i'm like well chances are i didn't look
at that in time and i sent it to the
wrong address
so i don't know what to tell you
sometimes i send free stuff oh
there was a smudge once little smudge
but the dude's a collector i got it so i
was like look send it back i'll give you
some extra goodies and stuff i'll i'll
sign it i'll make it better
i mean then they could just clone you
they just take your dna just take your
little fingerprints
i always tried it i always try to do the
right thing right i always try to make
everybody happy and that's my problem
because i can't make everybody happy
complete some of the people some time a
few of the people a few
a few of the time but you can't please
all the people all the time that's just
the way it goes
no i don't know uh again my patrons who
make this show possible in so many ways
first of all thank you westwood one
thank you ryan for amazing editing and
engineering
bryce for producing and really sticking
with me sticking with me guys
uh i appreciate it i love the podcast a
lot of people really love the podcast so
um i want to thank those guys for
sticking with the podcast my patrons if
you want to join patreon
again patreon.com inside i'll message
you back
as soon as possible uh here are the
wonderful uh top tier patrons who i send
the merch every three months or every
four months and i
uh you know write little personalized
notes and hopefully they're enjoying
their time as a top-tier patron
uh and also thank you for coming to
stage a few weeks back and supporting
the band we play every last saturday the
month
2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific standard time
show uh
here are the patrons nancy d mary b leah
s trish
f sarah v little lisa you could go jill
e brian h lauren g
nico p you can see them right here
they're on youtube look at this it's
just
amazing technology wow uh robin s jerry
w
robert i jason w apothean apathy
kristen k amelia o allison olg allison l
jess
j lucas m raj c joshua d emily s
cjp samantha m jennifer n jackie p stacy
l
carly h carly s jan s jamal f
janelle b carrie b tab of the 272 not to
be confused with
uh 273. that's correct
jesus ashley ryan kimberly mikey
and eldon supremo dan jack
s love ya ramirez beth b santiago m
sarah f chad w
liam p rey a maya p myeshia c
maddie s kendrick larsley shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v kevin v
james r chris h
amy c dave h samantha s spider-man chase
sheila g ray h
alyssa c tabitha t misha h tom n henry s
katie f liliana a michelle k hannah b
michael s
talia m luke h and here's the last
patrons john s andrew t can we have
music please
claire m liz j laura l chad l
rochelle e nathan e brandel taylor k
neil a
marion e meg k jannelle p dan n
jennifer j wayne m diane r ojeda
lorraine
g olga c corey m carrie h veronica k
big stevie w and kendall t those
are the top tier patrons uh and i
thank you for the continued support and
love and i hope you are continuing to
love the show
and um i try to message you when i can
it's it's it's not easy
let's do a youtube live soon too we've
got to play some music in the request
line so
my patrons make sure you come to the
youtube live
right now we only get a couple hundred
where you'd think all the patrons would
come to it but
they're busy they have things going on
in their lives people got stuff to do
you look at [ __ ] to do man
uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you from
my home in the hollywood hills of
california i was trying to do trumpets
like the
show tune keep doing it
i'm michael rosenbaum
i'm ryan yep that and uh we love you
guys
and we have a little wave to the camera
hey thanks so much for uh
joining me on this tuesday i know you
guys are busy or whatever day it is on
your way to work
on your way home if you're having a
tough day i wish you the best day i hope
it gets better it will get better
we got to make the most out of this life
that we're given
and i appreciate everybody and all their
support
[Music]
thanks